Back in 1991, a guy in Florida named Arnold Abbott started a charity helping the homeless. They gave out blankets and shoes and soap, served 1,100 meals a week. Helped people get jobs. He called the charity "Love Thy Neighbor." A few years later he was contacted by a woman in Michigan named Catherine Sims, who runs a ministry and business there called "Love Your Neighbor."
早在1991年，佛罗里达州有一位名叫阿诺德·阿博特的男子，开始从事慈善活动以帮助无家可归者。他们分发毯子、鞋子和肥皂，每周提供1100份餐食。他还帮助人们寻找工作。他将慈善机构命名为“爱你的邻居”。几年后，密歇根州一位名叫凯瑟琳·西姆斯的女士联系了他，她在当地经营着一个名为“爱你的邻居”的事工和企业。
She has a cable access show that's on from time to time in Detroit, and a prayer line she advertises in USA Today. She sells t-shirts and bracelets. She had actually trademarked the name "Love Your Neighbor" as the name of her business and ministry. Love Thy Neighbor just seemed too close to Love Your Neighbor to her. People might want to donate to her, but then give the money to him instead. She tried to convince him to change the name. First politely. Now, she's suing him.
她在底特律偶尔会播出电视节目，还在《今日美国》上宣传她的祈祷热线。她卖T恤和手镯。她实际上已经注册了“爱你的邻居”这个名字作为她企业和事工的名称。她觉得“爱你的邻居（Love Thy Neighbor）”和她的“爱你的邻居（Love Your Neighbor）”听起来太像了。人们可能本想捐给她，结果却把钱给了他。她试图说服他更改名字。起初还比较客气。现在，她正在起诉他。
She demanded that I cease and desist using the name Love Thy Neighbor. Turn it over to her and turn over all profits I've made.
她要求我停止并禁止使用“爱你的邻居”这个名字。要求我把它移交给她，并上交我赚取的所有利润。
Wait, she wanted profits you had made?
等等，她想要你赚到的利润？
Yeah, all the money I'd make taking money away from her since she owns the name, she said.
是的，她说既然名字归她所有，我从她那里抢走生意赚到的每一分钱都得给她。
At this point, I have had to hire an attorney in Detroit, Michigan to represent us. I had to send a retainer of $5,000, which translates into over 13,000 meals for the homeless. That's what it amounts to. We can put together a beautiful meal for about $0.38. So that's where you have it. And right now it's taking money out of-- food out of the mouth of the homeless to defend this kind of lawsuit.
此时此刻，我不得不聘请底特律的一位律师代表我们。我得预付5000美元的律师费，这相当于无家可归者13000多份的餐食。事情就是这样。我们大概只要38美分就能做出一顿丰盛的饭菜。所以情况就是这样。现在为了应对这场诉讼，不得不从无家可归者的口中夺食。
She, herself, is religious. Does follow the precepts of Jesus Christ. And she is trying to do God's work, following her very strong scruple.
她本人很虔诚，确实遵循耶稣基督的教义。她是在追随自己强烈的良知，试图完成上帝的事业。
Catherine Sims wouldn't talk to us. Julie Greenberg is her attorney. She points out that US Trademark Law requires anybody who holds a trademark on a name to go and fight off other people who try to use the same name, even if it's a homeless shelter with 100 volunteers serving 6,000 needy people on a budget of $50,000 a year.
凯瑟琳·西姆斯不愿接受我们的采访。朱莉·格林伯格是她的律师。她指出，美国商标法要求任何拥有商标权的人，都必须出面打击那些试图使用相同名称的人，即使对方是一个只有100名志愿者、年预算5万美元、服务6000名贫困者的无家可归者收容所。
In Trademark Law, the only real issue is who used it first in general. And in this case, Reverend Sims used it by 10 years first.
在商标法中，唯一真正的问题是谁先在普遍意义上使用了它。在这个案例中，西姆斯牧师比他早用了10年。
When did Reverend Sims first use it?
西姆斯牧师是什么时候开始使用它的？
1982.
1982年。
If your opponent in this case, if the charity Love Thy Neighbor down in Florida, were to employ the principle, love thy neighbor as thyself, in your view, what would they do?
如果你的对手，也就是佛罗里达那个叫“爱你的邻居”的慈善机构，真的运用了“爱邻如己”的原则，在你看来，他们会怎么做？
He's causing trademark infringement by using this particular choice of words. Pick any other words. Any other words that don't cause confusion and everybody would be better off.
他使用这个特定的词组就是在侵犯商标权。换个词吧。任何不会引起混淆的词都行，这样对大家都好。
But if the idea of the principle is that you treat your neighbor as you would be treated, the way that she would want to be treated is that he would give up the name. Why doesn't she just give up the name?
但如果这个原则的核心是己所欲者施于人，那么她所希望被对待的方式应该是让他保留这个名字。她为什么不干脆让出这个名字呢？
Well, because she has far too much to lose. And I don't think any doctrine of either biblical or civil law requires people to give up something of value to avoid a conflict.
嗯，因为她损失太大了。我不认为无论是圣经还是民法中的任何教义，要求人们为了避免冲突而放弃有价值的东西。
Both sides in this dispute claim that they are only trying to love their neighbor. Each side prays to the same God and quotes the same Bible. Neither side wanted a result as astonishing as a lawsuit, but the lawsuit came.
这场纠纷中的双方都声称他们只是在试图爱他们的邻居。双方都向同一个上帝祈祷，引用同一本圣经。双方都不想要一场如此惊人的诉讼结果，但诉讼还是来了。
Today on our show, people who think that they are good people, good neighbors, who ended up doing the least neighborly things possible. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We bring you three stories today of three neighborhoods.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要介绍一些自认为是好人、好邻居，却最终做出了极不友善行为的人。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们将为您带来三个关于三个社区的故事。
Act One, Mr. Rothbart's Neighborhood. That act is a story from a few years back in which an average Chicagoan decides to appeal the disputes and problems in his neighborhood to a higher authority, Mr. Rogers. Yes, that Mr. Rogers.
第一幕，罗斯巴特先生的社区。这一幕是一个几年前的故事，讲的是一位普通的芝加哥人决定向更高权威——罗杰斯先生，去诉说他邻里间的纷争和问题。没错，就是那位罗杰斯先生。
Act Two, The Little Girl Next Door. So a neighbor kid wants to befriend you, talks to you. She gives you presents, she hangs around. What if you don't want a very young new friend?
第二幕，隔壁的小女孩。有个邻居小孩想和你交朋友，跟你说话。她给你礼物，在你身边徘徊。如果你不想交一个这么小的新朋友怎么办？
Act Three, The Ratman Cometh. The story of a close-knit neighborhood. People who only want the best for all concerned. And coming from the house of a favorite neighbor, dozens and dozens of rats. And there is nothing they can do about it. Stay with us, my friend.
第三幕，鼠人来临。这是一个关系紧密的社区的故事。人们只希望为所有人争取最好的结果。但从一位受人喜爱的邻居家里，跑出了几十只又几十只老鼠。而且他们对此束手无策。留下来，我的朋友。
Act one, Mr. Rothbart's neighborhood.
第一幕，罗斯巴特先生的社区。
Davy Rothbart lives on Chicago's west side. But our story with him today really begins before he knew any of this current neighbors. Back long ago when he had one special neighbor.
戴维·罗斯巴特住在芝加哥西区。但我们今天和他之间的故事，其实在他认识任何现有的邻居之前就开始了。很久以前，他有一位特别的邻居。
When we were kids, my brother Mike wrote a letter to Mr. Rogers. My brother was six, I was three.
我们小时候，我哥哥迈克给罗杰斯先生写了一封信。我哥哥六岁，我三岁。
On a recent show, a deaf woman had paid Mr. Rogers' Neighborhood a visit and my brother wanted to tell Mr. Rogers about our mom because she's deaf too.
在最近的一期节目里，一位聋哑女士参观了《罗杰斯先生的社区》，我哥哥想告诉罗杰斯先生关于我们妈妈的事，因为她也是聋哑人。
A few weeks later an envelope addressed to Mike appeared in our mailbox. It was a letter from Fred Rogers. My whole family was pretty excited. Mike wrote to Mr. Rogers again, and they began a little correspondence. The next summer my family was headed to Massachusetts for a week's vacation and Mr. Rogers invited all of us to chill with him for a day at his summer home on Nantucket Island.
几周后，邮箱里出现了一个写给迈克的信封。那是弗雷德·罗杰斯寄来的信。我全家人都很兴奋。迈克又给罗杰斯先生写了信，他们开始通信。第二年夏天，我们家要去马萨诸塞州度一周假，罗杰斯先生邀请我们全家去他在南塔克特岛的避暑别墅和他待一天。
Here's what I remember. A long, long car trip. An afternoon's ride on a great big ferryboat. And then we were clattering down a gravel road and my mouth said, there's Mr. Rogers' house. We knocked on his door and there he was. The way I remember it, Mr. Rogers had in his house the entire set from the neighborhood of make believe. King Friday was there, Lady Elaine, X the Owl, Daniel Striped Tiger.
我还记得那次经历：一段非常非常长的车程。下午坐了一艘大渡轮。然后我们的车在碎石路上咯哒咯哒地响，我嘴里喊着：那是罗杰斯先生的房子。我们敲了敲门，他就在那里。我记忆中，罗杰斯先生的家里布置了整个“假想社区”的布景。星期五国王、伊莱恩女士、猫头鹰X、丹尼尔条纹虎都在那里。
We played way past dinner time and into the night.
我们玩到了晚餐时间以后，直到深夜。
I can't say I'm a grown-up now, but I have grown up. And there's some things about that visit with Mr. Rogers that just don't quite make sense to me now. I mean, why would a guy-- even Mr. Rogers-- interrupt his vacation to hang out with a couple of kids? Were we the only kids he'd ever invited to visit him, or was this a standard practice? And what was up with the whole Neighborhood of Make-Believe at his house? Could that really be true? I wanted to see Mr. Rogers again and ask him some of these questions.
不能说我现在是个成年人了，但我确实长大了。有些关于那次拜访罗杰斯先生的记忆，我现在回想起来觉得有点不对劲。我的意思是，为什么一个男人——即使是罗杰斯先生——要中断他的假期去招待几个小孩？我们是他邀请过的唯一孩子吗？还是这是惯例？他家里的那套“假想社区”是怎么回事？那真的会是真的吗？我想再次见到罗杰斯先生，问他这些问题。
So the day before my 26th birthday, This American Life producer Alex Blumberg and I flew to Pittsburgh, Mr. Rogers hometown, for another visit. We got picked up at the airport by his PR director, a guy named David Newell. You might known him as Mr. FcFeely, the mailman on the show.
所以在我就要过26岁生日的前一天，《美国生活》的制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我飞往罗杰斯先生的家乡匹兹堡进行另一次拜访。我们在机场被他的公关总监接走了，那个人叫大卫·纽厄尔。你可能知道他就是费克利先生，节目里的邮递员。
One speedy delivery later, we're in the same room with Mr. Rogers.
经过一次快速投递后，我们和罗杰斯先生共处一室。
Hi Mr. Rogers. Hi. Good to see you.
你好，罗杰斯先生。你好。很高兴见到你。
Welcome. I'm glad to see you after all these years.
欢迎。很高兴多年后还能见到你。
It's been a while.
确实过了很久。
I should say. You were about this big.
我是说，你当时只有这么大。
Well, the last time I saw you, you could lift me up in your arms. I don't know if that'd be possible now.
嗯，上次见你时你还能把我抱起来。不知道现在还有没有可能。
Well, I could try. How's your mom?
嗯，我可以试试。你妈妈好吗？
She's doing real well.
她很好。
It's taken six months to arrange this meeting. Mr. Rogers is an incredibly busy man. And his staff, though they're kind and well meaning, is protective of his time. There had been some debate about where we'd meet with Fred. We finally settled on the WQED studios, where Mr. Rogers has filmed his show for the last 30 years. Because, as his chief assistant told me, Fred feels most comfortable around a piano.
这次会面花了六个月才安排好。罗杰斯先生是个极其忙碌的人。他的员工虽然善良且好意，但对他的时间非常保护。关于在哪里和弗雷德见面，我们曾有过一些争论。我们最终定在WQED演播室，那是罗杰斯先生拍摄节目的地方，已经30年了。因为正如他首席助理告诉我的，弗雷德在钢琴旁感到最自在。
Welcome to this neighborhood. Oh, is this it?
欢迎来到这个社区。噢，是这里吗？
This is me visiting you on Nantucket.
这是我拜访你在南塔克特时的照片。
I show Fred the pictures of my family visiting him when I was four. In one of them he's in beach clothes holding me in his arms, my parents on either side. I ask him what he remembers about our visit, but it was a long time ago. He's met thousands of kids since then. And though he's too polite to say it, I don't think he remembers me specifically. Or what we did that day.
我把家里人拜访他时的照片拿给弗雷德看，那时候我四岁。其中一张照片里他穿着沙滩装抱着我，我的父母站在两边。我问他还记不记得我们那次拜访，但那是很久以前的事了。此后他见过成千上万的孩子。虽然他太礼貌没有直说，但我觉得他不记得具体是我了。也不记得那天我们做了什么。
But ordinarily I would play and ask the children to sing, It's a beautiful day in-- you know? And sometimes I would ask children-- I don't know whether I ask you. But I would ask them if they could recognize different characters from the Neighborhood of Make-Believe.
但通常我会弹琴，并让孩子们唱“这是一个美好的一天……”，你知道吗？有时我会问孩子们——我不知道我是否问过你。但我会问他们是否能认出“假想社区”里的不同角色。
That's what I remember.
我还记得那个。
Do you remember that?
你记得吗？
Yeah, I remember us-- I thought, well, this can't be right. I remember there being the entire set of the Land of Make-Believe in here in this building in this picture. But then, you didn't have all the set and the cast and everything. But just the fact that the puppets were probably there.
是的，我记得我们——我当时想，这不可能是真的。我记得这栋楼里有整套的“假想之国”布景，就像照片里那样。但当时你并没有把所有布景、演员什么的都放那儿。但木偶很可能是在那儿的。
They may not have even been there. The sound of them could have been there.
它们甚至可能都不在那儿。可能只是传出了它们的声音。
Meow, meow, beautiful meow. Meow, meow, Henrietta meow, meow cat.
喵，喵，美好的喵。喵，喵，亨丽埃塔，喵，喵。
Now that's Henrietta Pussycat.
那是亨丽埃塔猫。
And I'm X the Owl, I was just flying around looking for all of you. Hey, welcome to this neighborhood.
我是猫头鹰X，我刚才飞来飞去到处找你们呢。嘿，欢迎来到这个社区。
Up till now, I've never interviewed a dude who punctuates his points by pulling puppets out of a little gym bag and talking in the voice of an owl. But with Mr. Roger's, it doesn't seem weird. It's hard to describe his presence exactly, the strength of it. When you talk with him, he's utterly engaged. He asks a lot of questions and he seems to actually care about what you say. He let's the feelings come right to the surface. I've never been around someone who's both so vulnerable and so fearless about showing you who he is. Still, playing pretend with him, sometimes you just don't know what to say. It was Daniel Striped Tiger that finally tripped me up. Listen for when I lose it.
到目前为止，我从未采访过一个通过从健身小包里掏出木偶，并用猫头鹰的声音说话来强调观点的人。但对于罗杰斯先生，这并不显得怪异。很难准确描述他的存在，那种力量。当你和他交谈时，他会全神贯注。他会问很多问题，而且他看起来确实很关心你说的话。他让情感直达表面。我从没见过一个人既如此脆弱，又如此无畏地向你展示他是谁。不过，和他一起玩假装游戏时，有时你就是不知道该说什么。最后让我语塞的是丹尼尔条纹虎。听听我是什么时候失去镇定的。
I'm still pretty shy.
我还是很害羞。
Hi Daniel.
你好，丹尼尔。
Hi, how are you Davy?
你好，戴维，你好吗？
Good to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
Thanks and this one stripe of mine is awfully itchy. I wonder if you could scratch it?
谢谢，我身上这条纹痒得厉害。我想知道你能不能帮我抓抓？
I'd be happy to.
我很乐意。
That's it. Oh boy, that feels so good. I was a factory reject.
就是那儿。噢，天哪，感觉真好。我是一个出厂缺陷品。
What do you mean by that Dan? You look all right to me.
丹，那是什么意思？你在我看来很好啊。
The thing is, I never looked like a fierce tiger. And hardly any tiger lives in a clock. But that's who I am. And after a while, if you get to know me, you probably accept me exactly as I am. The way I accept you.
问题是，我看起来从来不像只凶猛的老虎。而且几乎没有老虎住在时钟里。但我就是这样。过了一会儿，如果你了解我，你可能会像我接受你那样，确切地接受我。
That's wonderful.
那太棒了。
When I told people at my neighborhood I was going out to visit Mr. Rogers, they kept wondering the same thing. What would Mr. Rogers do if he had to deal with the problems in our neighborhood? Fred agreed to talk to me about what goes on there and share his thoughts.
当我告诉社区里的人我要去拜访罗杰斯先生时，他们一直在想同样的事情。如果罗杰斯先生不得不处理我们社区里的那些问题，他会怎么做？弗雷德同意和我谈谈那里发生的事情并分享他的想法。
So come with me, won't you, to my neighborhood. A very special place I call the 1800 block of West Augusta. Our first stop, Julie, who doesn't like the loud music from the apartment below.
那么，跟我来吧，去我的社区看看。一个我称之为西奥古斯塔街1800号街区非常特别的地方。我们的第一站，朱莉，她不喜欢楼下公寓传来的吵闹音乐。
I get the broom, the weapon of choice, and I come out and I pound it on the floor.
我拿起扫帚，那是我的武器，走出来用力敲地板。
Show me how that sounds.
让我看看那是什么声音。
[POUNDING]
[敲击声]
OK, the truth is her loud downstairs neighbor-- it's me.
好的，事实是楼下那个吵闹的邻居——就是我。
Just a few little--
只是几下而已……
Well, Davy, you know it wasn't just a few. That's a leading question. You're leading the witness. It can be more if the music doesn't get turned down immediately. I've only done this twice. I've only done it twice. Haven't I?
嗯，戴维，你知道那不仅仅是几下。这是一个引导性问题。你在引导证人。如果音乐不立刻关掉，敲得会更多。我只做过两次。真的只有两次，不是吗？
Actually, the way I remember it, they were banging on the floor a couple nights a week for a month. Finally one night I went upstairs, acting all innocent. Look, what's going on up here? We're trying to get some rest downstairs, but there's this constant hammering sound. Is everything all right? I think I had Julie's husband, Greg, kind of discombobulated. He was like, I think that's my wife. The music.
其实我记得的是，他们一个月里每周有几个晚上都在敲地板。终于有一天晚上，我假装无辜地走上楼去。看，这上面怎么了？我们楼下想休息一会儿，但一直有这种敲击声。一切都还好吗？我想我当时让朱莉的丈夫格雷格有点困惑。他说，我想那是我妻子。音乐的事。
The turf war actually began the first day my roommate and I moved in. We'd play music. Julie would send Greg to knock on our door. Or sometimes just bang that broom on the floor. We eventually worked out that quiet hours would start after 10 PM. But still, sometimes we'd have friends over and yeah, we'd play our music anyways.
这场领地之争其实在我室友和我搬进来的第一天就开始了。我们会放音乐。朱莉会派格雷格来敲我们的门。或者有时就直接用那把扫帚敲地板。我们最终商定晚上10点以后进入安静时间。但有时我们还是会有朋友过来，嗯，我们还是会放音乐。
Me and my roommate, we both figured Julie was crazy. And actually, we kind of felt sorry for Greg. But I guess our music was pretty rough on her.
我和室友都觉得朱莉疯了。老实说，我们甚至还有点同情格雷格。但我猜我们的音乐对她来说确实挺刺耳的。
It's like if you're being tortured in a prison camp. They do something to you enough. After a while, you're like, ah, stop the madness. It's just the bass sound. It's just kind of a thumping sound. And I don't know why, it just drove me insane. And so even it was a little bit, Greg wouldn't even be able to hear it and I'd be like, oh my God, do you hear that?
就像如果你在战俘营里被折磨，他们对你做同样的事足够久。过了一会儿，你就会想，啊，快停止这疯狂吧。那只是低音，那是一种砰砰的震动声。我不知道为什么，它就是让我发狂。即使只有一点点声音，格雷格可能都听不到，我也会说，噢上帝，你听到了吗？
Let's check back in with Mr. Rogers for a quick second. Here's his take on things.
我们回去找罗杰斯先生确认一下。看看他的看法。
Good for you, Julie. I hate loud music.
做得好，朱莉。我也讨厌吵闹的音乐。
Hey, you're taking her side. You haven't even heard the whole story.
嘿，你在偏袒她。你还没听完全部故事呢。
Oh, OK.
噢，好吧。
Well, no, that is the whole story. OK, you're on her side? But Fred, it's my space. Can't I listen to loud music in my space? I mean, what's wrong with that?
嗯，不，那就是全部了。好吧，你站在她那边？但弗雷德，这是我的空间。我就不能在自己的空间听大声的音乐吗？我的意思是，那有什么错？
You can, but you can put headphones on. Now silence, we started with silence and I will always uphold a person's right to silence. But I'm super sensitive about this stuff. I am so sensitive that sometime-- I was in Florida not too long ago and the traffic was so loud that I slept in the closet. I took the cushions from the couch and made a bed in the closet.
你可以，但你可以戴上耳机。现在关于沉默，我们从沉默开始，我永远支持一个人拥有沉默的权利。但我对这些东西超级敏感。我敏感到了什么程度——前不久我在佛罗里达，交通太吵了，我竟然睡在衣柜里。我把沙发垫拿来在衣柜里铺了张床。
That's what I should suggest to Julie.
那正是我应该建议朱莉做的。
Go into the closet.
躲进衣柜。
Exactly.
没错。
I have a feeling you're getting to know Julie though. And once you do know her, then either your music isn't going to bother her so much or you're going to care so much about her that you'll probably turn it down a couple notches anyway.
我觉得你正在了解朱莉。一旦你了解了她，要么你的音乐就不会那么让她困扰，要么你就会非常在意她，无论如何你大概都会把音量调低几档。
How'd you know that?
你怎么知道的？
Mr. Rogers had broke it down perfect. That's exactly what's happened between me and Julie. We're not fighting over music anymore.
罗杰斯先生分析得太完美了。这正是发生在我与朱莉之间的事情。我们不再因为音乐而吵架了。
I think for a lot of people, the only way they come in contact with their neighbors is through conflict. I might not have even gotten to know Greg and Julie if she wasn't always banging on the floor. But while the three of us were hanging out that night in their apartment, they told me a story that, at the time, I didn't pay any attention to. But later, made me see something.
我想对很多人来说，他们接触邻居的唯一方式就是通过冲突。如果不是朱莉一直敲地板，我可能根本不会认识格雷格和朱莉。但那天晚上我们三个人在他们公寓里聊天时，他们告诉了我一个当时我没在意，但后来让我看清了一些事情的故事。
There's an invisible architecture that links together the folks who share a neighborhood. Greg and Julie were talking about our landlady's dog. Not the one she has now, but her old dog, the one that disappeared mysteriously. Greg had the inside scoop from the landlady.
有一种无形的结构将分享同一个社区的人们联系在一起。格雷格和朱莉当时正在谈论我们房东的狗。不是她现在养的那只，而是她以前那只神秘失踪的狗。格雷格从房东那里得到了内幕。
I had asked her what had happened to the dog and she said she let it out and somebody stole it.
我曾问她那只狗怎么了，她说她把它放出去，然后有人偷了它。
So we were kind of like, you know what? Nobody would have stolen that dog. Nobody would have stolen that dog. That dog was so old it was-- what is that word when you can't-- incontinent.
所以我们当时的感觉是，你知道吗？没人会偷那只狗的。没人会偷那只狗。那只狗老得——那个词叫什么——失禁。
A few days later I ran into my neighbor from across the street, Mike. A guy who makes his living fixing cars. Not in a shop, he just lines them up by the curve in front of his apartment. And my landlady's dog came up again out of nowhere. We were just BSing about something totally different, the meaning of the word "neighbor."
几天后，我在街对面遇到了邻居迈克。一个以修车为生的人。他不在修理店修，只是把车停在他公寓前的路边。我房东那只狗的话题又不知怎么出现了。我们本来是在胡侃一些完全不同的东西，探讨“邻居”这个词的含义。
To me, a neighbor is a friend, like family. But there's some people that no matter how much you try to be nice, they're unappreciative. Like the landlady from here. She accused me one day of stealing her dog. It sounds a little funny, but it's true. And the dog was just about as old as she is. What would I want with a dog-- he was so old he couldn't even hardly walk or see.
对我来说，邻居就像朋友，像家人。但有些人无论你怎么试图友好，他们都不懂得感恩。比如这里的房东。有一天她指控我偷了她的狗。听起来有点滑稽，但这是真的。而且那只狗跟她一样老。我要一只连走路或看东西都困难的狗干什么？
Mike's a good guy. He's like the unofficial mayor of my neighbor. He knows everybody. He's always waving. His daughter asked him once if his arm gets tired by the end of the day. Now and then I see Mike going up and down the street with a big broom, a one man volunteer cleaning brigade. He's not the kind of guy who steals dogs from old ladies.
迈克是个好人。他就像我社区非官方的市长。他认识每一个人。他总是挥手打招呼。他女儿曾问他一天下来胳膊会不会酸。时不时地，我看到迈克拿着一把大扫帚走在街上，像一个志愿清洁队的成员。他绝不是那种会从老太太手里偷狗的人。
But she's 80 something years old, so I understand. She's a little senile. So my sister had a beautiful dog. She had the shots for it, paid for the shots. She had the license, everything. I went out of my way. I gave it to my neighbor Jeannie and told her to give it to her, the landlady here. And I gave it to Jeannie to give to her because if I would have gave it to her, she probably wouldn't have taken it. And to this day, she does not know that I gave her that dog.
但她都80多岁了，所以我能理解。她有点老年痴呆。所以我妹妹有一只漂亮的狗。她给它打了疫苗，付了疫苗钱。它有执照，什么都有。我特意这么做。我把它给了邻居珍妮，让她转交给房东。我给珍妮是因为如果我自己给她，她很可能不会收下。直到今天，她都不知道那只狗是我送给她的。
I don't need to tell you, this is the kind of story Mr. Rogers likes to hear.
不用我说，这就是罗杰斯先生喜欢听的故事。
My, what a tender heart. And that'd be somebody that you'd like to know. Is this somebody that you know?
天哪，多么温柔的心啊。那一定是你很想结识的人。是你认识的人吗？
Oh, I know him well, yeah. He lives across the street from me.
哦，我非常了解他，是的。他就住在我街对面。
What a fine young man.
多么好的年轻人啊。
Across the street from my apartment there's a boarded up building that everyone says used to be a brothel. The next building over belongs to a kid named Hoppy and his blind grandfather, Pete. About 15 or 20 folks stay at their place. More than once I've seen the cops go in there and bring someone out in handcuffs. Hoppy and Pete keep a kind of used car lot going on the street in front of their building. Cars that Mike fixes up. In fact, I bought my car from them, a '73 Ford LTD. Every time I pull up Mike whistles and shakes his head and says, "It's a cruiser, man. It's a cruiser."
在我公寓街对面有一栋封起来的大楼，大家都说过去是妓院。旁边那栋楼住着一个叫霍皮的小伙子和他盲眼的祖父皮特。大约有15到20个人住在他们那里。我不止一次看到警察进去把人戴着手铐带出来。霍皮和皮特在他们楼前的街上经营着一个二手车生意。那些车都是迈克修好的。事实上，我的车就是从他们那里买的，一辆73年的福特LTD。每次我停下车，迈克都会吹着口哨摇头说：“这是台巡洋舰，哥们。这是台巡洋舰。”
These days, there's not as many old Cadillacs and Lincolns parked on the block at night. More Saturns and Explorers and shiny VW Jettas. Old buildings are being demolished. In their place, three storey condominiums sprout right up.
如今，晚上停在街区的老式凯迪拉克和林肯没那么多了。更多的是土星、探险者和崭新的大众捷达。老建筑被拆除。取而代之的是三层楼高的公寓。
The condos are taking over all our neighborhood. Our neighborhood ain't even here no more. It's gone.
公寓正在接管我们整个社区。我们的社区已经不复存在了。它消失了。
On the corner of [? Anre ?] and Iowa, just after dark, three teenagers were hanging out sipping duece deuces-- 22 ounce bottles of beer. Gustavo, Isaac, and Hernando, whose nickname is "The Mouth." And who has probably lived at 10 different apartments in a four block radius.
在[Anre]和爱荷华街的拐角处，天刚黑，三个少年正聚在一起喝着“22盎司”装的啤酒。古斯塔沃、艾萨克，还有外号叫“嘴巴”的赫南多。他可能在方圆四个街区内住过10个不同的公寓。
Everywhere in this neighborhood, March Field and Cortes, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and Cortes, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and Cortes. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and Walcot. Chicago and Wood, everywhere, you name it. I lived all around here and I know more. I can't afford the rent. Papa's got to move out. But I still come back. I'll always be here. Regardless what? Who moves in, I'll always be here. You can take the gangbanger away from the hood, but you can't take the hood away from a gangbanger.
这个社区到处都是，马奇菲尔德和科尔特斯，[听不清]和科尔特斯，[听不清]和科尔特斯。[听不清]和沃尔科特。芝加哥和伍德，到处都是，随你怎么说。我住过这一带的很多地方，我知道更多。我付不起租金。老爸得搬走。但我还会回来。我永远会在这里。不管发生什么？无论谁搬进来，我永远都会在这儿。你可以把帮派成员从街区带走，但你带不走帮派成员骨子里的那份街区情节。
As gangmembers go, these guys are pretty low-key. They sell weed and hang out drinking. I had decided to talk to them because when I roaming my neighborhood talking to my neighbors, the same thing kept coming up. A lot of people were afraid of their neighbors. Who exactly are you afraid of?, I'd ask. They all answered the same way. The gangbangers. The kids in baggy jeans and basketball jerseys who cruise the neighborhood with their stereos bumping.
作为帮派分子，这些人相当低调。他们卖大麻，聚在一起喝酒。我决定和他们交谈，因为当我游走在社区里和邻居聊天时，同样的事情一直在出现。很多人都害怕自己的邻居。你到底害怕谁？我问。他们都以同样的方式回答：帮派分子。那些穿着宽松牛仔裤和篮球球衣，开着音响在社区里穿梭的孩子。
The gangbangers, they said. Those are the bad neighbors. I guess it's no surprise The Mouth had his own idea about who the bad neighbors are, the ones who fear and distrust him.
帮派分子，他们说。那是坏邻居。我想“嘴巴”对谁才是坏邻居有他自己的想法，对他来说，坏邻居就是那些害怕和不信任他的人。
There was a neighbor in the neighborhood that he didn't agree with what we did so much. So he's stand in his house with a video camera and record what we were doing. Try to bring it to the beat meetings. He used to follow us around with cameras. Literally, follow us around the neighborhood with cameras. And say, I'm going to call the cops on you. For what? We ain't bothering you. That's what I think the worst neighbor is. They come in here fearing us and maybe thinking that we're going to do this and do that. But we'll talk to you, you know what I'm saying, bro? We ain't animals, bro. We're normal people like you.
社区里有个邻居不太赞同我们的做法。所以他站在自己屋里拿着摄像机记录我们的行为。试图带到社区会议上去。他过去经常带着摄像机跟踪我们。从字面上讲，就是带着摄像机在社区里跟着我们。说，我要报警抓你们。为了什么？我们又没打扰你。那才是我认为最糟糕的邻居。他们带着恐惧走进来，可能觉得我们会做这个做那个。但我们可以和你谈谈，你知道我在说什么吗，兄弟？我们不是野兽，伙计。我们是像你一样的普通人。
Someone like me and him who don't have everything. We were drinking a Heineken. In their house, what do they do? They drink maybe some wine or something. And to us, where we're standing on a pavement, this is our house. I got an older relationship with his neighborhood than the building they live in.
像我和他这样没有拥有一切的人。我们当时正在喝喜力。在他们家里，他们做什么？他们可能喝点红酒什么的。对我们来说，当我们站在人行道上时，这里就是我们的家。我对这个社区的关系比他们住的那栋楼要深远得多。
[SINGING] You are the only one like you, like you, my friend. I like you.
[歌唱] 你是唯一像你一样的人，像你一样，我的朋友。我喜欢你。
Here's the bridge. In the daytime--
这就是桥段。在白天——
Back in Mr. Rogers' neighborhood, we talk things over. Whether it's music, or a dog that's vanished, or neighbors who fear each other. It becomes clear that what he'd do in any of these situations is pretty much the same.
回到罗杰斯先生的社区，我们一起商讨事情。无论是音乐、消失的狗，还是互相恐惧的邻居。显而易见，他在任何这些情况下会做的事情其实都是一样的。
I can tell you what I would hope that I would do. I would hope that I would be brave enough to visit. It's so easy to condemn when we don't know. And if I would visit you and find out that you are a reasonable person, I could tell you about my sensitivities and see if it would make any difference to you.
我可以告诉你我希望我会怎么做。我希望我有足够的勇气去拜访。当我们不了解对方时，去谴责太容易了。如果我拜访你，发现你是一个通情达理的人，我可以告诉你我的敏感之处，看看这是否会让你有所改变。
It's funny, a lot of the things, like--
很有趣，很多事情，比如——
Producer Alex Blumberg comes in with a questions.
制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格插话提问。
You said if you were in Davy's neighbor situation, you said that you hoped you would have enough courage to go down and visit. And a lot of what you were finding when you were talking to people had to do with that same sort of notion. And I'm wondering, what is it that we're afraid of do you think?
你说过如果你处在戴维邻居的那种情况，你希望你有足够的勇气去拜访。而你在和人交谈时发现的很多事情都与这种观点有关。我想知道，你认为我们害怕的是什么？
Perhaps we think that we won't find another human being inside that person. Perhaps we think that, oh, there maybe are people in this world who I can't ever communicate with. And so I'll just give up before I try. And how sad it is to think that we would give up on any other creature who's just like us.
也许我们认为在那个人内心深处找不到另一个人。也许我们认为，噢，这世界上可能有些人是我永远无法沟通的。所以我会在尝试之前就放弃。想到我们会对任何和我们一样的人放弃，那是多么令人悲哀啊。
Half the people around here wouldn't even-- if they would listen to this tape they wouldn't put that three faces that are behind the talking. They wouldn't put it together because they wouldn't sit there and think that we're intelligent enough to think. To sit there and think about stuff like that that happens in everyday life. They look at us as kids that are just probably doing bad. They don't need to do that because we don't look at them and say, oh, they're rich snobs. We say it's a person carrying their life, doing what they're doing. Minding their business. Just because I carry my life in a different way, you don't have to fear me. We'll talk to you, have a good time. Maybe we got stuff in common.
这儿的一半人根本不会……如果他们听了这个录音，他们甚至不会把那三个说话的声音和背后的人联系起来。他们不会坐在那儿思考，认为我们有足够的智慧去思考。去坐下来思考这种在日常生活中发生的琐事。他们看着我们，只觉得我们是可能在做坏事的孩子。他们没必要那样，因为我们没看着他们说，噢，他们是富有势利眼。我们说那是一个背负着生活的人，做着他们正在做的事。忙着他们自己的事情。仅仅因为我背负生活的方式与众不同，你不必害怕我。我们可以和你谈谈，玩得开心。也许我们有共同点。
A few weeks ago in the middle of the night there was a huge fire in the building next door to Hoppy and Pete's. Nobody seemed to be hurt. Every one on the block came out of their buildings and stood on the sidewalks, watching the blaze and looking around at each other. Everyone in t-shirts and bathrooms and nightgowns, blinking their eyes, the light from the fire on their faces. In a moment like that, it doesn't seem like it would be that hard for everyone to just see each other as people, the way Mr. Rogers and The Mouth both talk about. But you know how it goes.
几周前的半夜，霍皮和皮特隔壁的大楼发生了大火。似乎没人受伤。街区里的每个人都从屋里出来，站在人行道上看着火光，互相打量。每个人都穿着T恤、浴袍和睡衣，眨着眼睛，火光映在他们的脸上。在那一刻，大家像罗杰斯先生和“嘴巴”所说的那样，仅仅把对方看作一个人似乎并不那么难。但你知道事情往往是怎么发展的。
After an hour, the firemen rolled up their hoses, the trucks drifted away, and everyone disappeared back into their own apartments.
一小时后，消防员收起了软管，消防车开走了，每个人又消失回了各自的公寓里。
Davy Rothbart. He's the creator of Found magazine. His new book, Found Two comes out this month as he heads out on a 36 city tour. Details at www.foundmagazine.com.
戴维·罗斯巴特。他是《Found》杂志的创办人。他的新书《Found Two》本月上市，他即将开始36个城市的巡回宣传。详情见www.foundmagazine.com。
[MUSIC- "DEAR HEARTS AND GENTLE PEOPLE" BY BING CROSBY]
[音乐 - 宾·克罗斯比的《亲爱的人们与温和的人们》]
Act Two, The Girl Next Door.
第二幕，隔壁的女孩。
So you want to be a good person, you want to be a good neighbor. But most of us have gotten into a situation at one point or another when that was just not very easy. Cheryl Wagner tells this story.
所以你想做一个好人，你想做一个好邻居。但我们大多数人都曾陷入某种情况，那时要做到这一点并不容易。谢丽尔·瓦格纳讲述了这个故事。
The little girl next door is driving me crazy. I think she wants something from me. Tucker says I'm just imagining it. She must be about 11 now, a medium brown, black, maybe Spanish girl with hair tied back in a perfect bun.
隔壁的小女孩快把我逼疯了。我觉得她想从我这儿得到什么。塔克说我只是在想象。她现在一定有11岁了，肤色中等偏棕，黑色头发，可能是西班牙裔女孩，头发扎成了一个完美的圆髻。
In the time that I've lived next door to her. she's grown about two feet and gotten her first real bike, a Walmart mountain bike. At first she only turn circles in her small front yard and navigated the cracked sidewalks between our houses. But now she's gone biking for hours at a time. I'd tell you her name, but I've blocked it. She knows mine, though I don't remember ever telling it to her.
在我住在她隔壁的这段时间里，她长高了大约两英尺，并拥有了她的第一辆真正的自行车，一辆沃尔玛的山地车。起初她只是在自家小院里转圈，在两栋房子之间破裂的人行道上骑行。但现在她一骑就是几个小时。我本可以告诉你她的名字，但我已经把它屏蔽了。她却知道我的名字，尽管我不记得曾告诉过她。
We both live in shotgun, so the alley between our houses is about five feet wide. Maybe smaller. Sound ricochets up, amplified and bouncing between our houses into my windows. I hate that.
我们都住在这种狭长的单室屋里，两栋房子之间的小巷大约五英尺宽。也许更小。声音在那儿回荡，被放大，在两栋房子之间反弹进我的窗户。我讨厌那样。
Since I started growing tomatoes, bananas, eggplant, whatever I can get to sprout in my backyard, the little girl has been hanging around on the wood stoop outside her bedroom door overlooking my backyard. Ariella. That's her name. It just snuck up on me when I wasn't trying to think of it. I had just turned 30 and I'm already losing my mind.
自从我开始在后院种植西红柿、香蕉、茄子，随便什么我能种活的东西后，那个小女孩就一直挂在她卧室门外的木台阶上俯瞰我的后院。阿里拉。那是她的名字。它在我没刻意去想的时候就溜进我的脑海。我才刚满30岁，就已经要疯了。
OK, so first Ariella liked my dog, Buster.
好吧，起初阿里拉喜欢我的狗，巴斯特。
Is that a hot dog?, she'd ask.
那是热狗吗？她会问。
A basset hound, I'd say.
巴吉度猎犬，我说。
Why is he so short?
为什么他那么短？
He was made like that so he could sneak under bushes in the woods better when he's hunting foxes in another country. France maybe.
他天生就是这样，这样他在另一个国家（也许是法国）猎狐时，就能更好地钻进灌木丛下。
He hunts?
他会狩猎？
No. Well, yeah. But just chicken bones and beer and French fries and stuff when we go on walks. No foxes here.
不。嗯，是的。但当我们散步时，他只会猎取鸡骨头、啤酒和薯条之类的东西。这里没有狐狸。
Is he a pit bull, the boy cousins would say when they came over. He mean?
他是比特犬吗？当她的男孩表亲们过来时会问。他凶吗？
No, Ariella would boss.
不，阿里拉会发号施令。
Sometimes I would hear her through my back screen door whispering Buster's name over and over through the chicken wire fence I made so he wouldn't escape and go eat stuff under people's houses.
有时我会听到她通过后纱门对着我做的鸡丝网围栏反复低语巴斯特的名字，那样他就不会跑出去吃人家房子底下的东西了。
Ariella's cousins would come over and I think maybe they were slipping my dog candy and chewies and bubble gum. Because I would find wrappers all around Ariella's little stoop by my fence. She and Buster fell in love because he wags himself in half when she says his name. Wish I was like that.
阿里拉的表亲们会过来，我觉得他们可能在偷偷给我的狗喂糖果、磨牙棒和泡泡糖。因为我会在阿里拉靠着我围栏的台阶周围发现包装纸。她和巴斯特坠入了爱河，因为当她喊他的名字时，他会摇尾巴摇到半截。希望我也能那样。
Here comes the bad part. This spring Ariella gets a plant and puts it out of her side stoop by where I'm gardening and waters it when I'm gardening. And her plant does OK for a while. But she doesn't water it every day, so it starts to brown and curl. So I begin watering it for her.
坏部分来了。今年春天，阿里拉得到了一株植物，把它放在离我园艺区很近的侧门台阶旁，每当我做园艺时她就浇水。她的植物起初长得还可以。但她不是每天都浇水，所以它开始变黄、蜷缩。所以我开始帮她浇水。
One day I give her six Miracle-Gro sticks to bury near its roots. Because it looks so wilty I feel bad for her. Other than that, I try not to get involved because I know how attached kids around here can get. Does that make me a bad person?
有一天，我给了她六根奇迹肥料棒，让她埋在根部附近。因为看它枯萎的样子，我为她感到难过。除此之外，我尽量不介入，因为我知道这附近的孩子们会有多依赖。这让我成了一个坏人吗？
Ariella's mother has this terrible boyfriend. He's tall, wide, imposing, bushy hair and beard. Old work truck. Brings craw fish, crabs, and fish by in burlap sacks that sit and steep in the sun in our alley. Drinks Miller tallboys until he's yelling on the front step. The works. Though in his defense I should say that he does toss the tallboys in our recycling bin, instead of on the ground or under the house.
阿里拉的母亲有个糟糕的男朋友。他高、壮、强悍，留着浓密的头发和胡子。开着老旧的工作卡车。带着小龙虾、螃蟹和鱼，放在麻袋里在巷子里的阳光下发酵。喝着米勒啤酒，直到他在门阶上咆哮。全套都有。尽管为他辩护，我得说他确实把酒罐扔进了我们的回收箱，而不是扔在地上或房子下面。
The boyfriend and the mother, a wiry woman in her late 30s, get drunk on Saturdays. Sometimes Fridays, Thursdays, and Sundays. And scream and yell and throw things while Ariella hides in her bedroom near my backyard. Which brings me to, is it just fighting or more?
男朋友和母亲（一个30多岁、干瘦的女人）在周六喝醉。有时是周五、周四和周日。大喊大叫，乱扔东西，而阿里拉就躲在离我后院很近的卧室里。这让我想到了，这只是吵架还是更严重？
I'm not opposed to calling the police when I hear what sounds like beating. No one has any visible bruises, but it sounds like chairs and couches against walls. Ariella's whole world being ransacked. I hear the fighting in my living room and in my bedroom even with mine and their music turned up. I hear fighting over my friend's band practicing next door. I hear fighting over their friend's screaming drunken 60 soul hits. The soundtrack to my life is Fats Domino, sad, old motown, all wailed against the other side of my wall, trying to submerge the neighborhood in dreamy water songs. Calm things down.
我不反对在听到听起来像殴打的声音时报警。虽然没有人有明显的淤青，但听起来像是椅子和沙发撞击墙壁的声音。阿里拉的整个世界都被洗劫了。我在客厅和卧室里都能听到吵架声，即使把我或者他们的音乐开得很大。我甚至在朋友乐队在隔壁排练时都能听到吵架声。我也能在他们朋友那撕心裂肺的醉酒灵魂乐中听到吵架声。我生活的原声带是胖子多米诺，悲伤的老摩城音乐，所有这些都在我墙的另一侧哀嚎，试图用梦幻的水之歌淹没这个社区。让事情平静下来。
Last spring, Ariella's mother sat with her on our side stoop and helped her with her homework. Ariella make straight A's. Some days I'd hear her mother calmly chiding her to clean up her room.
去年春天，阿里拉的母亲坐在我们的侧门台阶上帮她做家庭作业。阿里拉成绩全优。有些日子我会听到她母亲平静地叮嘱她打扫房间。
This summer rolled around quick, and now the lunkhead boyfriend's around all the time.
今年夏天很快就到了，现在那个笨蛋男朋友一直待在这儿。
What would I tell the police? I don't think Ariel should have to listen to all that? You are not going to stand there and talk to me like a bitch and use that language in front of my daughter.
我能告诉警察什么？我不觉得阿里拉应该听这些？你不能站在那儿像个婊子一样跟我说话，也不准在我女儿面前用那种语言。
One day I came home and there was a small manila envelope in my mailbox. It said, cheer up. Have a good day. From Ariella, the little girl next door.
有一天我回家，邮箱里有一个小马尼拉信封。上面写着：振作起来。祝你愉快。来自隔壁的小女孩阿里拉。
I opened up the envelope and there was a smiling wooden clothes pin with googly eyes glued to it. And I panicked. I called my mom and asked her what I should do.
我打开信封，里面是一个贴着大眼睛的微笑木制夹子。我惊慌失措。我打电话给我妈，问她我该怎么办。
She said, thank her.
她说，感谢她。
I said, I'm afraid she wants something.
我说，我怕她想要什么东西。
Don't scrutinize everything my mom said.
别深究一切，我妈说。
I didn't know what I wanted to give her in return. I couldn't just knock on her door and thank her face to face. I wound up picking some flowers I had grown and leaving them with a note on her front step one morning before I left for work. I don't know if she ever got them.
我不知道我想回赠她什么。我不能仅仅去敲门面对面感谢她。最终我采了一些我种的花，在我去上班前的一天早上把它留在了她的台阶上。不知道她有没有收到。
Recently I've stopped seeing her on the side stoop so much. She got her bike and started riding. Her mother casually says to me one morning, sorry if I was beating on your door and ringing your doorbell and screaming for help last night. My boyfriend had too much to drink and got a little crazy. I thought he was going to kill me. That's why the police were here. I told him not to come around anymore, but I don't know.
最近我没那么常在侧台阶上见到她了。她有了自行车，开始骑行。她母亲一天早上随口跟我说，如果昨晚我拍打你的门，按你的门铃尖叫着求救，很抱歉。我男朋友喝太多酒变得有点疯狂。我以为他要杀了我。这就是警察在那里的原因。我告诉他不准再来了，但我不知道。
Sometimes I want to take Ariella for an ice cream, but then I think how possible that is. An ice cream? I showed her a tiny wood Buddha once for a report she was doing for school and her mother was jealous.
有时我想带阿里拉去吃冰淇淋，但转念一想那有多大可能。冰淇淋？我曾经给她看过一个为了学校报告而雕的小木佛像，她母亲对此感到嫉妒。
Ariella's father drove in from out of town in a Mercedes SUV with this new wife and kid straight out of a Tommy Hilfiger ad last summer and picked Ariella up.
阿里拉的父亲去年夏天开着一辆梅赛德斯SUV，带着新的妻子和孩子，就像Tommy Hilfiger广告里走出来一样，把阿里拉接走了。
While she was gone, the mother kept stopping me on the sidewalk in front of our houses. She said that Ariella was excited because on her way home she was going to get to ride in an airplane. She said that Ariella had been scared to leave because she thought something bad was going to happen to her mother.
她离开的时候，她母亲一直要在我们房子前的人行道上拦住我。她说阿里拉很兴奋，因为回家的路上她要坐飞机。她说阿里拉一直害怕离开，因为她以为她母亲会出什么坏事。
I told her mother to call on the phone if she needed anything because my doorbell doesn't work. She said thanks, but she didn't ask for my phone number.
我告诉她母亲如果有事就打电话，因为我的门铃坏了。她说谢谢，但她没要我的电话号码。
A couple of weeks ago, Tucker hammered some rotten railings off the Ariella side of the house. Our slumlord was about to kick us out and sell the place. And all four of us were thinking about getting a low income loan and pitching in $200 each for the mortgage, so we wouldn't have to move to a dangerous neighborhood. We were trying to fix up the place for the government inspectors.
几周前，塔克把阿里拉那边房子上腐烂的栏杆敲掉了。我们的贫民窟房东正要把我们赶走并卖掉房子。我们四个人都在考虑申请低收入贷款，每人出200美元付首付，这样我们就不用搬到危险的社区去了。我们正试图为政府检查员修缮房子。
One of the rotten railings had a message penciled on it in a child's round handwriting. "You were not good neighbors," the railing said. "You never say hello."
其中一个腐烂的栏杆上用孩子圆润的字迹写着一行留言。“你们不是好邻居，”栏杆上写着，“你们从来不打招呼。”
When my old roommate loaned a little boy down the street from us a bike pump, the boy never brought it back. And then one of his cousins got shot. So my friend didn't want to ask for his pump back, even though he didn't have the money for a new one. Maybe that's how I feel.
当我以前的室友把打气筒借给街头一个小男孩时，那孩子再也没还回来。然后他的一个表亲被枪杀了。所以我朋友不想把他的气筒要回来，尽管他没有钱买新的。也许这就是我的感受。
Last night I cracked open the door because I heard slamming and cursing and someone yelling, is it going to be 911? I saw the mother's brother throw a 10-speed at her. I saw him shove her into the street. Ariella was standing on the front sidewalk near them the whole time holding a portable phone with her finger pointed at the dial. Ariella's in charge of dialing 911. She looked up over her shoulder at me.
昨晚我推开门，因为听到撞击声、咒骂声和有人在喊“那是911吗？”。我看到母亲的兄弟朝她扔了一辆10速自行车。我看到他把她推向街道。阿里拉一直站在人行道边上，手指一直指着拨号键。阿里拉负责拨911。她回头透过肩膀看了我一眼。
I shut the door. Tucker said, do not call the police. He'll know it was you. I said, I can't stand it. But I didn't call that night.
我关上了门。塔克说，别报警。他会知道是你报的。我说，我受不了了。但我那天晚上没报警。
Why did the police always tell when they say they won't?
为什么警察总是说他们不会泄露报警人，却又总是说出去？
The brother left and the shouting stopped. I called the YWCA 24 hour crisis line. They said, does the woman want help? We can't help people unless they want to be helped.
那个兄弟走了，叫喊声也停止了。我拨打了YWCA 24小时危机热线。他们问，那个女人想要帮助吗？我们不能帮助那些不想被帮助的人。
What about if there's a kid?, I said.
如果有个孩子呢？我问。
Do you have any reason to believe the child is being physically harmed in some way?
你有什么理由认为那个孩子正受到某种身体伤害吗？
Not physically, I said.
不是身体上的，我说。
Well, then no.
噢，那就不行了。
The next day the mother stopped me and said Ariella was worried about me worrying. I said I never know if I should call the police. She said only call if her boyfriend is trying to hurt her, not if her brother is trying to hurt her. Just the boyfriend. Then call. She kept apologizing.
第二天，她母亲拦住我说，阿里拉在担心我担心她。我说我从不知道该不该报警。她说只有在男朋友试图伤害她时才打，不是在兄弟试图伤害她时。只有男朋友。那样就报警。她一直道歉。
I want to get rid of my chicken wire and put up this big fence between our houses. I think about it whenever I go outside. Yesterday I went to the green project salvage place and picked out some metal grid. The week before, I bought one of those cheap rolls of bamboo.
我想扔掉我的鸡丝网，在两栋房子之间筑起一堵大围墙。每次我出门时我都会想到这一点。昨天我去了绿色项目回收中心，选了一些金属网格。前一周，我买了一卷廉价竹帘。
The other afternoon, Tucker helped me put it up, but none of it was tall enough. And this morning when I went outside, a breeze had knocked everything down.
前天下午，塔克帮我装上它，但没有一个高度足够。今天早上我出门时，一阵风把所有东西都吹倒了。
Cheryl Wagner, a version of her story originally appeared on the website openletters.net.
谢丽尔·瓦格纳，她故事的一个版本最初出现在openletters.net网站上。
Coming up, who let the rats out. Why that's never going to be the words to a hit song. In a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，谁把老鼠放出来了。为什么那永远不会成为热门歌曲的歌词。一分钟后，国际公共广播电台节目继续进行。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Class Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, neighbors and how even people who want to love their neighbors, want to love their neighbors as themselves, end up in confusion and in trouble with their neighbors. We have arrived at act three of our show.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是关于邻居，以及为什么即使是那些想要爱邻如己的人，最终也会陷入混乱，并与邻居产生麻烦。我们已经进入节目的第三幕。
Act three, The Ratman Cometh. Katie Davis has this story of people wanting to do the right thing on the block where she grew up in Washington, DC. The block where she still lives now.
第三幕，鼠人来临。凯蒂·戴维斯带来了这个关于我在华盛顿特区成长的那条街区上人们想要做正确事情的故事。那条我现在依然居住的街区。
Mostly coming up my block I get this cozy claustrophobic feeling. Two and three story row houses are squeezed together. There's the Nelson's house where I first got drunk playing cards. Next to it is Erica's dad's house where I heard about Nixon's enemy list. Two doors down is 1773 where Frank Sanchez's mother shot his father in the bathtub. We stayed up all night that night.
在我的街区上，我有一种舒适而幽闭的感觉。两三层的排屋挤在一起。那是尼尔森的房子，我第一次玩牌喝醉的地方。隔壁是埃里卡的爸爸家，我在那儿听到了尼克松的敌人名单。两扇门后是1773号，弗兰克·桑切斯的母亲在浴缸里枪杀了他的父亲。那天晚上我们熬了一整夜。
And then, in the middle of the block, right before you get to the fire house, the light opens up. A low stucco house stands apart, setback from the street. It's an old farmhouse really, painted peppermint green and surrounded by a saggy picket fence. The oldest house on the block, built when there were just fields here.
然后，在街区中间，在到达消防站之前，光线变得开阔。一栋低矮的灰泥房子矗立在那里，从街道退后。那其实是一栋古老的农舍，涂着薄荷绿，四周环绕着松垮的尖头篱笆。这是街区里最古老的房子，建在这里还是田野时。
Bobby, who grew up a block over says, it's the kind of house he and his friends went to on purpose on Halloween to scare themselves. We stand on the sidewalk looking through the pokeweed and overgrown bushes, which come up to our shoulders.
住在隔壁街区的鲍比说，这是他和朋友们万圣节特意来吓唬自己的地方。我们站在人行道上，透过美洲商陆和茂密的灌木丛看着它，那些植物长到我们的肩膀那么高。
It's closed up. There's no sign. It looks like no one lives there. And there's sheets in the windows. There's no lights hardly ever on in there. So it's just a spooky place.
它关着。没有招牌。看起来没住人。窗户上挂着床单。那里的灯几乎从不亮。所以那只是个诡异的地方。
The house belongs to Mrs. G. She's 85 and has lived on my street since the 1940s. Although she acts like she's still on the farm she grew up on in North Carolina. I see her scatter food scraps for the birds like her yard is a chicken coop. But the bread crumbs and fish heads draw more rats than sparrows. It stinks so bad that the UPS man, Gancy, he won't go to the door anymore and he just leaves her packages in the yard.
房子属于G太太。她85岁了，从1940年代就住在我的街上。尽管她表现得好像还住在北卡罗来纳州她长大的农场里。我看到她像在鸡舍一样为鸟儿撒食。但面包屑和鱼头吸引的老鼠比麻雀还多。气味太难闻了，UPS快递员甘西再也不去敲门了，只是把她的包裹留在院子里。
Neighbors wonder about it all the time.
邻居们一直对此感到奇怪。
I've seen the backyard. I've seen the front yard. I've never seen anything inside the house. Only rumors. The only thing I know about the interior of that house I believe is all rumor.
我见过后院。我见过前院。但我从未见过屋子里的任何东西。只有传闻。我所知道的关于那所房子内部的一切，我相信都是传闻。
I stood at the front door and I saw a beautiful painting inside the entry. And there were cockroaches, literally crawling around the painting.
我站在前门看到入口处有一幅美丽的画。而蟑螂正真切地在那幅画上爬行。
Her stepson showed me pictures of the interior. It was filled, filled, filled with debris.
她的继子给我看了内部的照片。里面堆满了，堆满了，堆满了碎屑。
Mrs. G will sit on a cement bench in the middle of the pokeweed all day. She used to be there with her worty looking dog, Morgan. But he died a few years ago. She took a bad turn after that. Started looking raggedy and wearing pants and shirts with big tears.
G太太整天坐在商陆丛中间的水泥长凳上。她过去常和她那只长着赘疣的狗摩根待在那里。但他几年前死了。她之后状况急转直下。开始看起来邋遢，穿着破了大洞的裤子和衬衫。
I find myself looking away when I'm talking to her because it feels wrong to get a glimpse of her pale, creepy skin.
当我跟她说话时，我发现自己会转过头去，因为瞥见她那苍白、令人毛骨悚然的皮肤让我感到不对劲。
Around the time that Morgan died, the rats really started taking over. Marin lives three doors down in 1773.
在摩根死后那段时间，老鼠真的开始占领那里了。马林住在三门后的1773号。
I have seen these rats. I'll be talking with Mrs. G on the sidewalk and behind her, the rats will be in front of her door just hopping. Like playing tag in broad daylight, my goodness. They're very bold. They felt very well at home because she ignores them, chooses not to see them. Or maybe she even feeds them. Perhaps they're her pets. I don't really know.
我见过这些老鼠。我会和G太太在人行道上聊天，在她背后，老鼠就在她门前跳跃。简直是大白天在玩捉人游戏，我的天哪。它们非常大胆。它们感觉自己像在家里一样自在，因为她忽视它们，选择看不见它们。或者也许她甚至在喂它们。也许它们是她的宠物。我真的不知道。
Rats act different at Mrs. G's house. Out of the blue about a year ago, Judith my neighbor, the lawyer, she called to say Mrs. G pets the rats.
老鼠在G太太的房子里表现得与众不同。大约一年前，我的律师邻居朱迪思打电话来说G太太在抚摸老鼠。
Have you seen her, Judith?
你看到了吗，朱迪思？
No. She said, but Bebe has.
没有。她说，但贝贝看到了。
When I asked Bebe, Bebe said, I didn't see her, someone else did. No matter, Mrs. G is now the lady who pets the rats.
当我问贝贝时，贝贝说，我没看到她，别人看到的。没关系，G太太现在就是那个抚摸老鼠的女人。
On the one side and Mrs. G's there's the fire house and on the other, there's Bebe and Fernando and their three kids. They've lived next door for 20 years. And in the last four, it's become horrible.
G太太房子的一侧是消防站，另一侧是贝贝和费尔南多以及他们的三个孩子。他们已经在隔壁住了20年了。在过去的四年里，情况变得糟糕透顶。
A few months ago, the family cat and dog, Gata and Tinkerbell started to sit like statues in the kitchen pantry. Just sit there, staring at a big bag of pet food. At first, Bebe and Fernando thought their pets had suddenly becomes really smart, able to communicate that they were hungry. When they moved the pet food though, they found a huge hole in the pantry floor. Rats had gnawed through the brick, through the mortar, and electrical wiring, right into their kitchen. That same day, Fernando went out and bought a bunch of rat traps.
几个月前，家里的猫和狗，加塔和叮当仙子开始像雕像一样坐在厨房的储藏室里。就坐在那儿，盯着一大袋宠物食品。起初，贝贝和费尔南多以为它们的宠物突然变得很聪明，能交流它们饿了。但当他们搬动宠物食品时，发现储藏室地板上有一个巨大的洞。老鼠已经穿过砖块、砂浆和电线，直接啃进了他们的厨房。同一天，费尔南多出去买了一堆捕鼠器。
The first time that I got one, there was like-- this was a six inch big rat over there.
我抓到的第一个，大概有六英寸大。
You caught one in the house?
你在屋里抓到的？
Oh yeah, right here. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] the sink.
噢是的，就在这儿。[听不清] 水槽底下。
Mrs. G is lucky that her next door neighbors are Fernando and Bebe. They are both community activists. They believe in compromise and working things out. Sit with them a while and they'll tell you that it hasn't been all bad living next to her. That she's great with their kids and their pets.
G太太很幸运，她的隔壁邻居是费尔南多和贝贝。他们都是社区活动家。他们相信妥协和解决问题。和他们坐一会儿，他们会告诉你住在她隔壁并非全是坏事。她对他们的孩子和宠物很好。
She's part of this community. One of the best community member that we have. She walks the street all day. She talks to people. She's very friendly to all the people on the block. She say hi to everyone. She knows who is who on the block. And every one of us talk to her. We are not walking away from her. We don't screaming to her.
她是这个社区的一部分。是我们拥有的最好的社区成员之一。她整天在大街上走。她和人说话。她对街区里的每个人都很友好。她对每个人都说嗨。她知道谁是谁。我们每个人都和她说话。我们不会避开她。我们不会对她大喊大叫。
It's true. Every month Mrs. G brings me a $20 bill for the neighborhood fund that helps pay rent for an elderly carpenter who can't afford the rising rents on our street. That's much more than some of the high-powered lawyers on the block have ever given.
是真的。每个月G太太都会给我一张20美元的钞票，放进邻里基金，帮助支付一位付不起街上日益上涨租金的老木匠的房租。这比街区里某些高权重的律师捐得还多。
For years, Bebe and Fernando have tried talking to Mrs. G about the rats. They've talked to her over and over. They offered to help her cleanup up her yard and the house. Mrs. G always says, I'll take care of it. But nothing gets done. And the rats keep multiplying.
多年来，贝贝和费尔南多一直试图和G太太谈论老鼠的事。他们反复跟她说过。他们提议帮她清理院子和房子。G太太总是说，我会处理的。但什么也没做。而老鼠一直在繁衍。
We really feel very much caught. This is an elderly person who clearly needs help. Our way and who we are does not allow us to impose certain kinds of things that would put her in a position that she would lose property or even her own freedom.
我们真的感到非常被动。这是一个明显需要帮助的老人。我们的方式和我们是什么样的人，不允许我们强加某些会让事情变得更糟的行为，那样会让她陷入失去房产甚至失去自由的境地。
This really drives Bebe crazy. She can fix most anything. I go to her when I'm stuck on tough problems. Tenants facing eviction, a suicidal teen, or a kid who can't read. Bebe always knows what to do. She started to feel trapped though, in her own house. She couldn't sit on her porch or leave her windows open because of the stench of the rats and the cats.
这真的让贝贝抓狂。她几乎能修好任何东西。遇到棘手的问题时，我会找她帮忙。面临驱逐的房客、有自杀倾向的青少年，或者读不了书的孩子。贝贝总是知道该怎么办。但她开始觉得在自己的房子里被困住了。因为老鼠和猫的恶臭，她不能坐在门廊上，也不能打开窗户。
It's not our nature to use enforcement. But here, this is a situation where there's very little we can do. We've done the talking. We've done the conversation. We try not to be the angry, mean neighbors. Let me tell you, I hear it from every neighbor on the block. And very often I hear, so why don't you do something about it?
这不是我们的天性，不是去使用强制手段的人。但在这里，情况是我们能做的很少。我们已经沟通过了。我们已经谈过了。我们尽量不做那种愤怒、刻薄的邻居。让我告诉你，我从街区里的每个邻居那里都听到抱怨。而且我经常听到：那你们为什么不采取行动？
So three years ago, Bebe finally called the Department of Housing and the Department of Health for an inspection. Nothing happened. Bebe called again, knowing full well that if the system ever got triggered, serious things could happen to her neighbor.
所以三年前，贝贝终于打电话给住房部门和卫生部门进行检查。什么也没发生。贝贝又打了电话，完全知道如果系统一旦启动，她的邻居可能会发生严重后果。
For a long time, Mrs. G was blessed with the amazing incompetence of the DC government. The sluggish workers charged with enforcement would get a call, put it on their list, and now and then get around to sending someone out. One day an instructor knocked on Mrs. G's door and was apparently chased away by rats. Or, I think she was swarmed by a pack of rats. That's what people say anyway.
很长一段时间里，G太太得益于DC政府惊人的无能。负责执法的人员会接到电话，把它记在名单上，然后偶尔才会安排人去看看。有一天，一名检查员敲开了G太太的门，显然被老鼠赶走了。或者，我想她是陷入了一群老鼠的包围中。反正大家都这么说。
Every time I asked Mrs. G if I could get her version of all of this in an interview, she said no. Sometimes nicely and sometimes not so nicely.
每次我问G太太我能否在采访中得到她的版本时，她都说不。有时很客气，有时很不客气。
Seeing the government failing, Judith, the lawyer, made a calculation that money might be the thing to move Mrs. G. She dispatched a developer to buy both her houses. With the DC housing boom, they're worth-- even in their terrible shape-- at least a million dollars. The developer called me to find out what I knew. And after a while, he laid his cards on the table.
眼看政府失败，律师朱迪思算计着钱可能才是让G太太动摇的东西。她派了一名开发商买下她两栋房子。随着DC房地产的繁荣，即使在现在这种糟糕的状态下，它们也价值——至少一百万美元。开发商打电话给我，想了解我知道些什么。聊了一会儿后，他摊牌了。
I just put my grandmother in a home he said and I can help Mrs. G get into one.
我刚把我祖母送进养老院，他说，我可以帮G太太住进去。
I was beside myself. I couldn't imagine anyone but Mrs. G in that house, rats and all. And what was this developer planning anyway? To whitewash the house? Maybe bulldoze it and build condos. You see, that's how rumors get started. I actively, viciously, spread rumors about this developer because I didn't like the way he said, "She deserves to live in a nice place."
我当时简直快疯了。我无法想象除了G太太，谁还能住在那个满是老鼠的房子里。这个开发商到底在打算什么？把房子重新粉刷？也许拆掉盖公寓。你看，这就是传闻怎么开始的。我积极、恶毒地传播关于这个开发商的传闻，因为我不喜欢他那种“她理应住在一个好的地方”的口吻。
I got my neighbors riled up. I dangled the gentrification threat, which worries old-timers on the block. I even got Fernando going. Even though a developer could be his salvation and his key to fresh air.
我煽动了邻居们。我抛出了绅士化改造的威胁，这让街区里的老住户很担心。我甚至把费尔南多也拉进来了。即使一个开发商可能是他的救星，是他呼吸到新鲜空气的关键。
I think that this anti-neighbor approach, that's really jeopardizing the neighborhood and the community. Because see, that developer coming is affecting every one of us. And that's the problem. Because I, as a neighbor, if I see that you're bringing in 50 unit building next to my house, I will scream and I will prefer to keep her.
我认为这种反邻里的方式，真的危及了社区。因为你看，开发商的到来影响了我们每个人。这就是问题所在。因为作为邻居，如果我看到你在我家隔壁盖一栋50个单位的大楼，我会大叫，我宁愿留下她。
In the end, it was Mrs. G who stonewalled the developer. Wouldn't talk to him, even after he left her flowers. She is masterful at sidestepping people.
最终，是G太太让开发商碰了壁。她拒绝和他交谈，即使在他留下鲜花之后。她在避开他人方面真是大师。
It's hard. I want Mrs. G to change. I want her to quit creating problems for my neighbors. And yet, I admire her stubbornness and tenacity. But you know, what is she holding onto? A big pile of putrid garbage and wet newspapers pasted thick with cat piss? This is something both Bebe And Marin have thought about.
太难了。我想要G太太改变。我想要她停止为我的邻居制造麻烦。但同时，我佩服她的顽固和坚韧。但你知道，她到底在坚持什么？一堆腐烂的垃圾和被猫尿浸透的湿报纸？这是贝贝和马林都想过的问题。
Clearly from conversations with her son and others, something drastically changed when her husband died. And somehow, a part of her has stood still.
从与她儿子的谈话中可以明显看出，丈夫去世时，有些事情发生了剧烈的改变。在某种程度上，她的一部分停在了过去。
She's talked about her husband a lot. It was a real love story. They were, I guess, sweethearts in high school. But then they married different people. And years later, they reunited and married. And it sounded like they were very much in love. I've heard neighbors say they used to walk down the sidewalk hand in hand.
她谈论她丈夫很多。那真是一段动人的爱情故事。我想，他们高中时是恋人。但后来他们分别嫁娶了别人。多年后，他们重聚并结婚。听起来他们非常相爱。我听邻居说他们曾经手牵手走在人行道上。
My Claude is what she calls him. My Claude could fix anything. There was a time when the Green house had all its shutters up, every picket in place.
“我的克劳德”，这是她对他的称呼。我的克劳德什么都能修。曾几何时，那栋绿房子百叶窗全开，每一根木栏都在原位。
I don't think Mrs. G counted on the DC government ever reforming. But two years ago, people elected a new mayor here and he set about coordinating city services. They started keeping a record of complaints and cross referencing them, getting the Department of Health to talk to the Department of Housing. And then, just when all that was in place last summer, Bebe took advantage of a windless day to sit outside on her porch to discuss a project with a colleague. And well, the rats started doing their thing.
我想G太太没指望DC政府会改革。但两年前，人们选出了一位新市长，他开始着手协调城市服务。他们开始记录投诉并进行交叉参考，让卫生部门与住房部门对话。然后，当所有这一切都在去年夏天就位时，贝贝利用一个无风的日子坐在门廊上和同事讨论一个项目。嗯，老鼠开始作乱了。
When Bebe's colleague got back to her office, which happened to be the office of the mayor, she made a few phone calls. That same day, Jose [UNINTELLIGIBLE], the new neighborhood services coordinator, got an assignment. Fix the problem at 1767.
当贝贝的同事回到她的办公室，那正好是市长办公室时，她打了几个电话。同一天，新任社区服务协调员何塞，接到了一个任务。解决1767号的问题。
Message one.
第一条留言。
Hey, Katie, this is Jose. You know that business about the mountain and Mohammad and like that? Let me tell you a specific reason for calling among many.
嘿，凯蒂，我是何塞。你知道关于穆罕默德和那座山之类的道理吗？让我告诉你，我打电话的众多原因中的一个特定理由。
It's funny how we're all connected. I've known Jose since I was a teenager at dance parties. He knows Bebe too. Their sons play together. So you can see where Jose might take the rats personally. Probably the most important thing to know is this. Jose has only had this job as a neighborhood fixer for a few months and he likes it. He has his own cellphone, a government car, and a really good salary. No way is he going to blow this job. He has to fix the problem at Mrs. G's house.
这很有趣，我们所有人都联系在一起。我从十几岁起在舞会上就认识何塞了。他也认识贝贝。他们的儿子常一起玩。所以你可以看到何塞为什么会把这些老鼠问题当成个人的事情。可能最重要的事情是这个：何塞担任这个社区维修员的工作才几个月，而且他喜欢这份工作。他有自己的手机、政府配车，工资也很不错。他绝对不会丢掉这份工作。他必须解决G太太房子的麻烦。
The situation at 1767 has reached what they call critical mass. Even the fire people next door are now complaining about the amount of rats in that house. And she's going to have to do something. I don't exactly know how we're going to approach this, but it's not going to be as kindly and careful as before because it really is--
1767号的情况已经达到了所谓的临界点。连隔壁的消防员现在都在抱怨那所房子里的老鼠数量。她必须采取行动了。我不知道我们具体会怎么处理，但不会像以前那样善良和谨慎了，因为这真的……
So Jose went out to talk with Mrs. G and he kept on going, pressuring her, pressuring me to pressure her. So I pressured Jim, the pastor up the street, to talk to her because Mrs. G will listen to a preacher over any of us.
所以何塞出去和G太太谈话，他一直坚持，给她压力，也逼我给她压力。所以我逼迫街头的牧师吉姆去和她谈，因为G太太会听传教士的话胜过听我们任何人的。
I think it was the preacher who convinced her to let Jose clean up her yard. We were all impressed. Mrs. G never lets anyone help her. She actually said, OK, come on Friday. And we did. Three fire marshalls, Gerard the rat man, Jose, two neighbors, and myself.
我想是那位传教士说服了她让何塞清理她的院子。我们都印象深刻。G太太从不让任何人帮她。她竟然说：“好的，周五过来吧。”我们也确实去了。三个消防局长、捕鼠人杰拉德、何塞、两个邻居，还有我。
Would you like us to help you out with the back of your yard?
你愿意让我们帮你清理一下院子后面吗？
No, that's what [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
不，那是……[听不清词句]。
She doesn't want our assistance now. How you doing?
她现在不想要我们的帮助了。你好吗？
How you doing, lieutenant?
你好吗，中尉？
It's also her birthday today too.
今天还是她生日。
When we get there, Mrs. G has beat us to it. The pokeweed, her beloved pokeweed is cut down to the ground. The bushes trimmed, all with her kitchen scissors.
当我们到达时，G太太抢在我们前面完成了。商陆，她心爱的商陆被砍倒在地上。灌木被修剪，全是她用厨房剪刀干的。
Mrs. G stands in her yard, the front door fully visible for the first time in six months. She lets me record this day, maybe because she thinks it will shield her from the city officials.
G太太站在院子里，前门六个月来第一次完全显露出来。她让我记录下这一天，也许是因为她认为这能保护她免受城市官员的骚扰。
Well, I just enjoy doing it myself. And I did it. And I was proud that I could do it myself.
嗯，我只是喜欢自己动手。我做到了。我很骄傲我能自己做。
Mrs. G is hoping she's done enough to make us go away. But everyone keeps offering to do more.
G太太希望她做的已经足够让我们离开了。但每个人都在不停地提出做更多。
You all must have been boy scouts.
你们肯定都是童子军吧。
Mrs. G is laughing, but I can tell her teeth are clenched. She never sounds this high pitched. She's really softer. Robbed of their mission, the city workers poke around for something they can do. Can we rake? No. Can we put a smoke detector inside your house? No. No thank you.
G太太在笑，但我能看出她的牙关咬得很紧。她从没发出过这么尖的声音。她平时声音更柔和。失去了任务的市政工作人员四处转悠寻找可以做的事。我们可以耙地吗？不。我们可以帮你屋里装个烟雾报警器吗？不。不，谢谢。
Jose is trying not to notice that his party is a bust. That he got us all here for nothing. He leans over to inspect a drain with Mrs. G.
何塞试图不去注意到他的聚会是一个败笔。他把我们都带到这里却什么也没干成。他俯身和G太太检查排水沟。
You're a tough, old lady.
你真是个强硬的老太太。
I've had to be.
我不得不这样。
I still don't get it. I really don't. Because I mean--
我还是不明白。我真的不明白。因为我的意思是……
Well, you're used to be people wanting help. I don't.
嗯，你习惯于人们想要帮助。我不想要。
Even what you've done in the garden, I mean it seemed to me-- I'd like to get some guy to help you trim the rest of it and clean the rest of it down. But you don't want to do that. You want to do it yourself.
即使是你花园里做的这些，我的意思是看起来……我很想找个人帮你修剪其余的部分，清理掉剩下的一切。但你不想那样。你想自己做。
Out on the sidewalk I pulled Gerard aside. He's a city rat exterminator and he is gentle, almost courtly with Mrs. G. He'd love to kill the rats in her yard, in her house. He'd be a legend in the rat world, if she would just let him.
在人行道上，我把杰拉德拉到一边。他是城市的灭鼠员，他对G太太很温和，几乎是彬彬有礼。他很乐意杀死她院子里、房子里的老鼠。如果她肯让他动手，他会成为灭鼠界的传奇。
I feel that she do't want us to do too much for her because she don't want people to know her. And the more she let people do for her, the more you'll know her.
我觉得她不希望我们为她做得太多，因为她不想让人们了解她。你让她为你做的事越多，你就越会了解她。
And what would we learn? That she doesn't mind roaches and rats? We already know that. I keep thinking about what Mrs. G said to Jose, "You're used to people wanting help." It's true, we all are. We figure if someone's alone and struggling with things, then all they need is their neighbor's help. And if a neighbor offers help, well, problem solved. It bugs us when people say no. It bugs me anyway.
我们又会学到什么呢？她不在乎蟑螂和老鼠？我们已经知道了。我一直在想G太太对何塞说的话：“你习惯了人们想要帮助。”这是真的，我们都是这样。我们认为如果有人独自一人在挣扎，那么他们只需要邻居的帮助。如果邻居提供了帮助，嗯，问题解决了。当人们说不时，这让我们很困扰。至少我很困扰。
I want to say to her, Mrs. G, you help Paul every month with his rent, why won't you let us help you?
我想对她说，G太太，你每个月都帮保罗付房租，为什么你不让我们帮你呢？
Three weeks ago, I went down to Bebe and Fernando's house. They're all dreading what's going to happen this summer. It's been eight months since the city came out and the weeds and rats are out of control again. Bebe says the cleanup was purely cosmetic. That no one ever makes a real dent in the problem.
三周前，我去贝贝和费尔南多的房子。他们都为这个夏天将要发生的事情感到恐惧。离市政府的人来过已经八个月了，野草和老鼠又失控了。贝贝说那次清理纯粹是装饰性的。根本没人能真正解决这个问题。
One of the things that I'm afraid also, is that at one point the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] rat is so big in that house and the house is too old that at one point the rats will eat one electrical wire and that will cause a major fire. And she will die and everyone will feel guilty for a couple weeks, and life is going on.
我担心的其中一件事是，有一点那房子里的老鼠太大了，而且房子太老了，到了一定程度老鼠会啃掉一根电线，那会引起一场大火。她会死，每个人会自责几周，然后生活继续。
We should call and get the house condemned Fernando says. Bebe looks at her husband and answers, OK, do it. Make the call. There's a pause and then he mutters, I feel too guilty.
我们应该打电话让这房子被判为危房，费尔南多说。贝贝看着她丈夫回答，好吧，去吧。打那个电话。沉默了一阵，然后他嘟囔着，我感到太内疚了。
Mrs. G goes to the grocery store every day. I look out my window and see her coming back from the Safeway dragging a cart full of cat food for the strays.
G太太每天都去杂货店。我看向窗外，看到她从Safeway回来，拖着一车猫粮喂流浪猫。
On Sundays though, Mrs. G combs her white wavy hair to the side, puts on a skirt-- the blue one usually-- and walks up to the Baptist church on 16th street. After the service, Sarah, the secretary at the church, comes and visits a while. They sit outside on the bench and talk. Never inside. Not even Sarah goes inside. If it's cold, they just zip their coats up.
不过在周日，G太太把她白色波浪状的头发梳到一边，穿上一条裙子——通常是蓝色的那条——走去16街的浸信会教堂。礼拜后，教堂的秘书莎拉会过来拜访一会儿。她们坐在外面的长凳上聊天。从不进屋。甚至连莎拉也不进去。如果天冷，她们就拉起外套拉链。
Next door, Fernando has come up with a new approach to his neighbor problems. Talking failed, government failed, and real estate money failed. He just installed an anti-rat device. An electronic box that sends out a signal painful to a rat's ear. From Mrs. G's yard with the pokeweed coming back, you can barely hear it.
隔壁，费尔南多想出了处理邻里问题的新方法。谈话失败了，政府失败了，房地产开发金也失败了。他刚安装了一个防鼠装置。一个能发出让老鼠耳朵感到疼痛的信号的电子盒。从G太太那商陆丛生回来的院子里，你几乎听不到那个声音。
Katie Davis lives on her block in Washington, DC.
凯蒂·戴维斯住在华盛顿特区的街区里。
Well, our program was produced today by Starlee Kine and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Blue Chevigny and Jonathan Goldstein. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Annie Baxter. Music help from Mr. John Connors.
好了，我们的节目今天由斯塔莉·凯恩和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、布鲁·切维尼和乔纳森·戈德斯坦。高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特管理我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和安妮·巴克斯特协助制作。约翰·康纳斯先生协助音乐。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free, or buy CDs of them. You can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以完全免费地收听我们的节目，或购买CD。您可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载节目的音频。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia, who-- I don't know. Is this right for a boss? He's constantly walking up to all of us in the hall and saying--
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他……我不知道。这对老板来说合适吗？他总是走到大厅里对我们所有人说——
This one stripe of mine is awfully itchy. I wonder if you could scratch it. Oh boy, that feels so good. I was a factory reject.
我身上这条纹痒得厉害。我想知道你能不能帮我抓抓？噢，天哪，感觉真好。我是一个出厂缺陷品。
And I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台，PRI。